the double slit experiment defies our
understanding it involves a laser
shooting beams of light particles called
photons at a screen with two parallel
slits if we Mark all the spots where the
photons hit the second wall we should
expect to see two strips to correspond
with the two slits but that's not what
we see instead we see an alternating
pattern of light and dark bands this is
characteristic of the behavior of waves
that pass through both slits
simultaneously interfering with each
other to create the pattern on the
second screen the bright lines are where
the top of waves meet resulting in a
more intense or brighter area on the
screen the darker bands are where the
top of one wave meets the bottom of
another so they cancel each other out
resulting in a less intense or darker
area on the screen here is a photo of a
real interference pattern the original
double slit experiment was conducted in
1801 by British polymath Thomas Young
since then it's been performed with
various types of particles including
electrons and they were found to behave
in the same way this phenomenon occurs
even if the photons are fired one at a
time which suggests that the photon is
interfering with itself as it passes
through both slits at once physicists
were so stumped that they decided to
observe which slit the particle went
through and that's when things get
really weird
when scientists used a measuring device
to observe the slit that each Photon
passed through the interference pattern
disappeared and the photons started
behaving like particles instead of the
spectrum of light and dark bands we see
two bright bands indicating that the
photons chose one slit or the other so
light can display characteristics of
both particles and waves known as wave
particle duality it appears that light
decides to behave as a wave when it's
not being watched and acts like a
particle when it is being measured the
mere Act of observing which slit it went
through changed the behavior of the
photons almost as if they were aware
they were being watched it's kind of
like how in a video game the environment
and objects only load when the player
focuses on or interacts with them the
entire world isn't rendered all at once
allowing the game to save processing
power and optimize resources likewise
light seems to behave like waves but
when we observe it it's as if we're
loading its properties causing it to
change and acts like particles physicist
Richard Feynman famously said the double
slit experiment is absolutely impossible
to explain in any classical way and has
in it the heart of quantum mechanics in
reality it contains the only mystery
the most widely accepted Theory to
explain this phenomenon comes from
physicist Niels Bohr who proposed that
particles like photons don't have
definite properties until they're
observed so in the case of light photons
exist in a wave-like form representing a
range of possible positions until they
are observed when we measure or observe
the particle we force it to choose a
definite State behaving like particles
this is called The Copenhagen
interpretation named in honor of Laura's
Home City however to this day no one
knows why observing a particle causes
Its Behavior to change
not everyone was a fan of his theory
Einstein disagreed that particles could
be in multiple States at once until
observed he was uncomfortable with the
inherent randomness of such an
interpretation and famously said God
does not play dice with the universe
Einstein believed that the Universe
followed a consistent set of rules like
how his general relativity Theory
predicted the motion of planets around
the sun he spent his later years trying
to develop a unified theory that
explained everything in the universe but
he didn't succeed
physicists recently conducted a
variation on the double slit experiment
in April 2023 researchers at Imperial
College London swapped out the screen
with two slits for a transparent
material used in smartphone screens
called Ito they first fired a laser beam
at the material when a second laser was
directed at the material and pulsed
super quickly in quadrillions of a
second it caused the material to become
temporarily reflective
the interaction of laser 2 with the
material changed the frequency and
therefore the color of the light from
laser one that was reflected off the
material this experiment shows that by
manipulating time rather than space they
were able to create interference
patterns similar to the interference
observed in the original double slit
experiment
there are certain things in life we take
for granted if you don't get enough
sleep you'll feel tired and groggy if
you drive recklessly you're more likely
to get into an accident but sometimes
there are principles that govern our
lives that we just can't explain
the perplexing result of the double slit
experiment is up for interpretation with
some suggestions that this is evidence
our world could be programmed
so far not even the best scientific
Minds can explain the bizarre behavior
of particles at least not yet
there are many puzzles that are
perplexing for example can you tell
what's wrong with the gears Leonardo da
Vinci wanted to use in his military tank
design from the 15th century this is one
of thousands of problems you'll find
unbrilliant a website and app where you
can learn stem interactively my viewers
especially love Brilliance lessons in
computer science data science and math
Da Vinci's tank design had a flaw in its
gear mechanism causing the front and
back wheels to rotate in opposite
directions so the tank will never be
able to move at all this was possibly an
oversight or an intentional mistake to
protect his design from being built
without his support for more puzzling
questions like this you can check out
brilliant for free for 30 days by
heading to the custom link in my
description
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 people who sign up with my link will
get 20 off their premium subscription
which gives you access to all the
offerings thanks for watching I'm Cindy
Palm